many of us have done things that we
regret like skipping a trip leaving a
relationship or walking away from a good
job a recent survey focuses on some of
the 47 million people who quit their
jobs during last year's so-called great
resignation about one in five of those
people who resigned during the pandemic
regretted it many of them wanted more
pay and responsibility then realized
their new gig wasn't the dream job they
wanted so what do they do now what do
you do now this is you linkedin career
expert career catherine fisher is here
with some advice to help workers bounce
back from a wrong move good morning how
you doing thanks for having me of course
now why are people regretting leaving
their jobs during the pandemic so those
of you who are you know unhappy with the
move it's probably because that you were
just moving too fast both on the company
side and on the employee side so what
happened is that these companies were
really trying to fill vacant roles and
been sitting for a long time so they
shortcut the system in terms of the you
know we saw some companies were taking
two weeks to hire people it's really
fast to make a decision on an employment
both for the person taking the job in
for the company and some people also we
saw on linkedin you know a woman was
talking about how she was lured to that
really big salary
but didn't take into account what is the
job what's my manager going to be like
you know how much accountability will i
have and so because of this hiring
process has really changed they you know
all of a sudden they didn't ask those
the right questions that you typically
do in the hiring uh process what are the
right questions catherine to ask so
because you're sitting out here on this
limb
sewing it and sawing so now what are the
right questions because you don't want
to make the same mistake twice yes and
what you want to do is make sure that
you're not asking really general
questions of like hey do you like
working here of course their job is to
sell you on the job so what you should
be asking is how do you celebrate wins
how do you celebrate failures like what
happens if you fail
give me an example of a time when the
team didn't have enough resources to do
a job how did you manage through that so
being really specific about what's
important to you to give you greater
insight into the culture but i would
also culture i never when i was looking
for a job ever asked about the workplace
did you no did you ever ask about
workplace culture ever yeah well culture
is very important and something that
many companies are really investing in
and a great thing to do though is beyond
just you know the people that you're
talking to on the interview panel is
talk to people outside of that interview
panel you can go to their you know
company page you can go figure out what
is it that you know see if you have any
one in common that you worked with you
know at that company or you know people
and talk to them about really what is it
like to work there you'll get the more
honest answer and take time to reflect
really ask yourself what do you need to
be happy so if you took a job during the
pandemic and now you realize it's not
the right fit which is what a lot of
people have realized um what should you
do because i would think that as a
manager
we were talking about impulse you look
at the person coming back to a job or
trying to get another job and go hmm you
strike me like an impulsive person not a
thoughtful individual that could be a
red flag yeah well you can be thoughtful
so i think what is really important is
to say you know i took this job i didn't
ask all the right questions that i
needed to and what i've discovered
during this you know three-month job
that i had is this is actually what's
really important to me and so if you use
that time to be self-reflective and be
honest about it i actually think it
makes you a strong candidate it's still
it's still a red flag though i would if
you didn't ask everybody employer is
going to say okay okay yeah we'll just
forget about that period of your life
and i mean i think it's a little tough
for people if you're going to make a
decision about bringing somebody in and
you want to assess the character of that
person
i don't know do you add that to the
resume if you're going to look for a new
job do you say oh i quit my old job
right and i was only there for a short
time but it's not what it looks like
no i would not add that part
and i actually would say you should yes
because i think you're being honest if
you're being honest and if you're saying
i took this job because this is what i
was looking for i realized that actually
what i need to be successful is i made a
mistake
yes i think people appreciate it when
you say you made a mistake yeah i just
don't do it all the time but that's yeah
just don't do it all the time there's a
lot of mistakes to be made but you say
despite these numbers the uh people
looking for work still have the upper
hand today they do you do yeah think
that
there's still a lot of companies looking
to hire people and i think that also
companies are doing a lot to attract
employees so they're doing things
obviously like with salaries sign-on
bonuses we're also hearing a lot of
companies doing things like upskilling
their workforce so paying for their
education so it really is still a great
time to look for i will say though that
for the people that leave that creates
opportunities for the people who stay ah
yeah this is true also important not to
burn bridges if you're gonna leave don't
do that rage quit and put put it on
instagram yes the worst thing you can do
is rage so what i'm hearing finding a
new job is like finding a new lover be
honest with what you want right it
absolutely is i hadn't thought of that
but now i am thinking about that are you
looking for a new puzzle no i'm just i
mean that's what i'm hearing
no it's like a relationship you're
getting in it is absolutely you got to
know what you need all right
it's not 50 shades of grey you know i'm
just saying
i'm taking notes okay i'm taking notes
thank you catherine fisher thank you
always good to see you